if you during covet during all this mess  you were loyal to your employer you can  go ask for a raise  if you were loyal you didn't play  gamesmanship you didn't bully the  employer you kept your head down you did  your part you've earned the right to go  ask because that is something that  companies value a lot and by the way  companies if you now obviously you can't  go out there and say give me a freaking  you know whatever percent raise I'm not  talking about that don't go so I think I  deserve this rates but you've earned the  right to ask for a raise  and if companies who bitched about the  fact that people were bullying you by  shopping the salary if you don't take  care of your employees who are loyal to  you you're just as guilty as those who  are bullying others because this season  is the season to reward loyalty because  there were a lot of people that were  loyal